haha get it because
tom holland robert pattinson
ah that's funny all right john you can
come in now i did all the funny already
opening bit taken care of
seriously dude like you're just in a hat
and a t-shirt that's the opening bit
i thought it would be funny man i
thought i thought i took care of the
funny already
you don't always have to be the star
like i went to all this trouble like
look at this this is less is more
i'm wearing a cape all right you know
how impractical these things are
you look like a dumbass i'm in character
i'm in character i don't know what that
bit was apparently tom holland and
robert pattinson are starting a movie
together on netflix
let's check this trailer out
[Music]
is he smoking a cig yeah man they were
good for you back then
this is
oh dude it's time to pass it on
it's the best present i ever got thank
you
tom holland with a southern accent yeah
man that's how you break out of being
british
how and why people from two points on a
map without even a straight line between
them can be connected
this is the heart of our story and knock
them stiff
you ever think about how we ended up
orphans living in the same house
i know what my daddy did
dude is that bill scott
robert justin
jason clark what is this cast oh yeah
blessed are they hungry and thirst
for righteousness whoa
that voice
we got time for our center
oh
[Music]
[Music]
wow
god this looks great damn this looks so
good
whoa
oh that looked amazing isn't it ah
i was so pleasantly surprised by that
trailer my god
i'm so happy it's great to have like a
film like this to be excited
that looks amazing yeah it really does
oh good you wanna know what's even more
amazing
not only did jake gyllenhaal produce
this
what other people but but i read earlier
this morning that
sebastian stan was originally his role
was supposed to be played by chris evans
who has no conflict who personally
recommended sebastian
for this movie so this is like a secret
marvel production it's
crazy yeah this is nuts okay i wanna get
a clear-cut idea of the plot
okay and knock em stiff
ohio it's neighboring backwards sinister
characters an
unholy preacher robert that's that's
like gold for for
a character actor yeah crazy twisted
preachers
all right mine's better twisted couple
jason clark and riley
cough
sebastian stan converge around young
arvin russell tom holland as he fights
the evil forces that threaten him and
his family spanning the time between
world war ii and vietnam war director
antonio
camposes the devil all time renders a
seductive and horrific
landscape that pits the just against the
corrupted
co-starring bill scars okay all right
wow
whoa i mean i didn't know anything about
it other than what's in the freaking
title of this video
and so as it kept going i'm like why are
there so many famous people
in here and it doesn't look like you're
you're just slapping on famous names
everyone looks like they're given a
juicy role something to really feed off
in here
it's great to see tom holland really
branch out right now with this kind of
character work you know i don't know how
people will feel about a southern accent
i've never been to the south
so what from my ears are hearing and i'm
like it sounds good
robert pattinson southern accent i love
that oh it's so deliciously eerie
everyone here looks great and i love the
mood and the tone netflix just
kills it at these like small town
southern dreadfilled horror movies that
are probably more
psychological character based than
anything else and i love this
vibe that they're giving off with trauma
and torture and some stuff feels like
you know you got these religious
undertones some people are believing it
to be at least in their faith
something that's supernatural really
it's not it's just a bunch of evil
sinful people at least that's the vibe
that i'm currently getting from the
trailer is like some stuff but
there might be some like imagery that
hints at something that's a little bit
more
hiding supernatural really it feels very
grounded i'm excited for this this looks
great this looks amazing yeah it really
gives you a sense of
permeating foreboding like the entire
time and it almost to me read like an
anthology but not
you know because it seems like we're
gonna spend or at least get to know
each of these central figures or repairs
in a way it almost
had me thinking of in a weird way uh
like bad times at the el royale
in a strange way not not that it would
be the same kind of movie but the the
kind of thing that has yeah a bunch of
colorful characters who are all going to
challenge you
and probably you know conflict you in
various ways you're probably going to
end up liking certain things about them
and hating other things
and uh funny enough sorry this thing's
very tight
um robert pattinson you mentioned his
southern accent when the trailer popped
up and uh i just watched
good time last night and that movie i
mean if you haven't seen it and you're
doubting robert pattinson
go have that nightmare it's great but he
i was watching an interview about it
afterwards and he said that part of what
he loves about getting into characters
is tapping into the accents
figuring out where a character is from
and reverse engineering kind of
through their speech because that's
exactly what daniel day-lewis says
yeah yeah you know somebody's accent
isn't only about where they're from it's
about their experiences too and and
and you know thinking about other people
in the cast especially tom holland like
i was thinking on the ride over like
i like tom holland because of spider-man
and stuff but i don't really
know as much of his true acting chops
and this is something that gets me
excited too to see what his range is
among all these other great actors too
because you know just whenever you hear
him talk he always seems like someone
who's motivated by the presence of a
great actor
to bounce off of he and jake gyllenhaal
are clearly bros now
yeah you know like he's producing this
so yeah i mean this looks really really
cool and uh yeah the kind of thing that
you know sometimes netflix's stuff
can have a certain budgetary ear mark
that feels a little tvs
and i feel like when you're doing
material that is a little more grounded
like this it's easier to kind of avoid
that
and so uh yeah this looks full-on this
looks like a dynamite you know
experience all the way around i mean but
we can't do this video without doing the
thing
we got batman we got spiderman
we
everyone's favorite alice got haley
bennett what else are you
in help us out haley bennett i know
we've seen haley yeah you're in some
fandom related thing you gotta be hating
you you gotta
oh yeah the equalizer is where we know
hardcore henry hardcore henry
yeah love that thank you for your
service uh uh swallow oh god damn it
uh all right who's right riley cook
riley kyo uh uh you i saw her in an
episode of riverdale
matt mad max fury road okay we did it
perfect
everyone karate character guys
if you like this trailer hit the like
button on our video
and if you liked our reaction hit the
like button subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified whenever we got a new
youtube video
leave your thoughts down below what you
thought of everything you saw here what
stands out to you the most last but not
least
got a shout out my homeboy cameron's
movie reviews
lights cameron action he is posting
non-stop over at his instagram page
anytime i come across one of his posts i
make sure to read through it i love
everything this guy does
if you are a cinephile if you are
someone who's into movies and perhaps
wrestling even make sure to go follow
this guy there's a link to his instagram
in the description box i'm telling you
guys
you won't regret it and by the way
camera appreciate all those uh
all the times you've been contributing
in our live streams all the super chats
took me a long time to realize like oh
that's not that you go by a different
name cracked the cameron code
so thank you dude for being you you mean
a lot to us you've been around for such
a long long time
like a very long time one of our longest
supporters actually now that i think
about it
yeah seriously geez oh wow
this is hitting me right now and yet you
still remain so mysterious i find that
so interesting about you
that's the mystique of cameron love you
buddy catch you soon
[Music]
you